brand new phase the stakes rising the
urgency
increasing now that both conventions are
over
president trump about to campaign in new
hampshire after his big rnc speech last
night
the president laying out his agenda
defending his record and offering up
blistering attacks on joe biden
take a look joe biden is not a savior
of america's soul if given the chance he
will be the destroyer
of american greatness they will make
every city look like democrat-run
portland oregon no one will be safe in
biden's america
at the democrat convention you barely
heard a word about
their agenda but that's not because they
don't have one
it's because their agenda is the most
extreme set of proposals ever put
forward by a
major party nominee joe biden's agenda
is made in china my agenda is
made in the usa
joe biden's plan is not a solution to
the virus but rather it's a surrender to
the virus
the president and republicans reaching
out to three groups of voters during the
rnc
maga supporters african-americans and
suburban swing voters so
were they successful in selling the
message
greg let's uh kick it off by saying hey
the virtual experiment
in conventions is over ratings were down
all around but the biden campaign today
bragging that their candidate speech got
more viewers than president trump's
speech
why do you think that was well probably
because there's
less that you've seen of joe biden so
they had to check him out
you could see you could see trump every
single day
he basically it's the trump show every
day but joe you know he's basically
you know uh he's like a mole he's just
living underground until he has to come
up every now and then
i thought last night was amazing and how
preferable
non-politicians are to politicians in
in terms of i don't know presenting
ideas uh
and being persuasive alice johnson i
mean don't just give her a pardon
give her a show she was she is an
absolute natural and i guess she she
learned i mean
i thought that she was impressive dana
white you know
a tough cookie incredibly forceful and
then you have
you know the and you know andorn who was
a voice that was neglected by the media
because her story didn't fit their
narrative
um you know because the media believes
certain lives matter more than
other lives and it was necessary to
remind everyone
that she lost her husband because when
you excuse the mob
you know the mob grows and people die
but when you look at everybody
you look at alice johnson dana white you
look at
jack brewer you look at burgess hershell
walker sister byrne
the idea of a republican party as a
country club
that cliche is dead it's
over that idea of a republican
republican party no longer exists
it's now the party of law-abiding
americans who want to live
free that's all it is it was a great
message
all right so jesse i want to hear your
thoughts because
you know when i was watching the speech
i thought it was very long it was
you know i think more than an hour it
seemed slow at points
and even the attacks on joe biden from
the president
and normally he's just so you know he's
got punch that guy can really
stir people up i just thought they felt
like reruns to me so
what was your view of the speech i'm
very angry with the president
i told him all week he needs to keep it
ending before 11 and he kept me up until
11
30. i'm a mess today juan i can barely
keep my eyes open but
i'm gonna just give him a pass on it i
know it was a very special night
i would disagree with you strongly i
thought it was an effective speech an
effective week they reignited the base
while also
extending a hand to other people the
framing of the fight against the
coronavirus as a war
and america always wins wars was very
effective
he really laid out what he accomplished
in the last four years basically stuffed
two terms into one which is pretty
incredible and then
cast out a vision for the future talking
about untangling
ourselves from china and making us the
manufacturing superpower
winning the race to 5g putting a man
on mars tax relief war on crime
it was a very uplifting message for the
second term but i did think he defined
biden as someone
who's been on the wrong side of history
as someone that's been on the wrong side
of every trade deal
every foreign policy decision as someone
who is beholden to the far left
and china and he kind of had a
rhetorical
flip-flop with joe's thing he said
during the dnc as he's
an ally of the light he said joe wants
to keep you in the dark
about what he wants to do because his
radical proposals are so dangerous
and he's a member of a party that can't
even keep the lights on
in a place like california where you're
seeing rolling blackouts so i mean
that's kind of like a management issue
and
donald trump wins that very effectively
the end
the historical flourish that he brought
together when he talked about
the american pioneer spirit that
forges a character by pushing forward
into the frontier defining us as rugged
individuals
with flair and style but we're
successful because we kind of work
together as one
and kind of weaving the america first
populous
movement into that historical momentum
and then casting out a vision for the
future that's what great leaders do
they kind of rally you behind a
patriotic momentum
with vision joe biden didn't even
attempt to do that
so the president was very i get the
message there
all right so martha one of the lines of
questioning today about the president's
speech
is did he make the case for what he
would do
if reelected in the next four years this
is coming from lots of people who say oh
he never answered sean hannity he can't
answer the new york times
did he do it in the speech last night
martha
well to a certain extent he tried to in
one of the
end sections of the speech he went
through a number of things he talked
about
uh creating 10 million jobs over the
next 10 months he talked about
wanting to go to mars putting a woman on
mars was one of the things that he
mentioned at the end
so he wants to push forward the space
program he talked about religious
liberty he talked about protecting
abortion rights he talked about
um increasing the economy so i i think
there were plenty of agenda items
that were there um and i think that you
know
i don't think that the overall delivery
was as strong as we
have seen in at certain times for the
president and i do wonder as i mentioned
last night
if it was a great strategy to put him
out there every single day because it
doesn't lead to that sort of
big moment when you've seen the
president so many times all throughout
the week
however we do see a lot of the president
uh in you know every 24-hour news cycle
is
as was pointed out one of the things
that i thought when you talk about
the groups that they want to inspire to
bring the vote out you've got the
make america great vote and then you've
got the
black american vote which obviously they
are trying to get as well and you've got
the women's suburban vote
and i thought that in many ways he tried
to appeal to all of them of course at
different points in the speech because
it was very long so it hit on pretty
much everybody
but in terms of the of the mega crowd
right one of the things that i thought
was a line that was so
potent that i haven't heard discussed
that much and i'm kind of paraphrasing
paraphrasing it a little bit but he
talked about joe biden
sort of talking the talk with
blue-collar workers
but not walking the walk he said he has
empathy
for blue-collar workers but he said then
he sends your jobs to china
and he sends your sons to war yeah and i
thought that was pretty powerful
you know you have to remember that when
you look at wisconsin and michigan and
pennsylvania the president won
in a combination of 70 000 votes in
those states
he knows he needs to win those states
he's behind in the polls in all of them
right now they say their polls look
better but those are the polls that
everybody else can can look at and see
um so he's got to bring out more people
that will resonate with that and he's
got to prevent joe biden
from from pulling those votes away from
him and i thought that was a pretty
powerful line of attack
that was interesting i haven't heard
much discussion of that katie
greg was mentioning david dorn's widow
now he is the
policeman who was killed by looters in
saint louis
today his daughters came out and said
they really
didn't want uh the widow to speak there
they said
david dorn was not a trump supporter and
that they felt
this politicized his death what do you
think i think the widow
of a woman who the widow the woman who
spoke andorn has
every right to speak wherever she wants
to about her husband
who was killed in cold blood after doing
a friend of favor and trying to keep his
business safe
you know i i'm not going to comment on
the family members but she was in the
crowd last night
at the white house on the south lawn
with her family
who happens to not share the same skin
color as her by the way
to listen to the president and you don't
have to be a trump supporter
to want safe communities and to want to
stop uh people from losing their lives
simply for defending the property that
they have worked so hard over a lifetime
to keep and to you know use to provide
for their family but i want to touch on
another issue real quickly before we go
um you know the speech that president
trump gave was long
but they were very strategic in
addressing every single issue so whether
if you're a single issue voter they went
through basically every single topic you
could imagine in that speech president
trump attacked joe biden's record
and then explained what his record is on
the issue after four years in the white
house and what he would do
in the future on the issue and i think
one of the most effective speeches to
speakers was ivanka trump because she
talked about how she's been in
washington
it's a tough place and her father has
forced her
to look at her own convictions about the
way that politics and policy
affect real people and president trump
was very effective
in showing people he's trying to get to
vote for him that he is still an
outsider
not a corrupted washington politician
after being here for four years and he's
going to continue
to keep at bay those temptations about
what dc can do
for people like joe biden who as martha
pointed out
said a whole lot of things to
blue-collar workers to union workers and
voted for the opposite when he was in
washington d.c
thanks katie